hey leute und will kommt zu einer neuen
folge von der ceo wir müssen wieder
richtig richtig viele sie zugesendet
bekommen wir mittlerweile richtig viele
sie täglich und da ist die entscheidung
wirklich immer schwer welche nicht
annehmen möchte allerdings habe ich mich
diesmal für den cee'd himmel arsch und
zwirn entschieden warum der sieht es
einfach so geile sind richtig hammer
sachen direkt nebeneinander quasi
verbundene verbunden sind jetzt eher so
im sprichwörtlichen teil aber ich
erstelle erstmal die welt der zeit wurde
mir übrigens bereitgestellt von der
pinguin mit pinguinen lux genau sein
kommentar
beziehungsweise seine nachricht an mich
wird oben eingeblendet bitte wenn ihr
einzieht fest schreibt die mir bitte als
kommentar und nicht so viel als
nachricht denn ich bekomme mittlerweile
täglich ungefähr 50 nachrichten nur mit
zieht also nachrichten sind echt für
private sachen und solche zieht sachen
bitte in die kommentare schreiben
danke so here's pont wir schon gesehen
habt hier direkt vor dem tempel ihr geht
in den tempel einfach mal rein geht nach
unten moment ich muss mir eine fackel
holen stimmt das wollte ich machen
jetzt kommen wir natürlich wieder die
fallen ließen sie mich ab aber da das
ist ein diamanten und vier knochen ich
weiß nicht ob er noch irgendwo eine
kiste ist ich bin mir gar nicht so
sicher wie hier ist nur diese tripwire
hier ist dieser dieses komische
schalterrätsel es hat sich irgendwas
getan
ich weiß nicht genau was pro na ja keine
ahnung was ich jetzt hier getan hat aber
auch relativ egal jedenfalls ist da halt
ein diamant drin in der kiste
dann fliegen wir mal ganz kurz hier raus
moment wogegen zu lang ich glaube ja
hier gings lang ihr wisst immer noch
genau da sind wir gespannt ihr fliegt
quasi in diese richtung hier ist erstmal
ein sehr schöner berg sehr viele
schweine und tada hier ist direkt ein
skelett spandau wo auch ein bisschen
eisen redstone sattel und ein eimer drin
ist also auch ein paar witzige sachen an
die verfolgen mich jetzt richtig weg
naja jedenfalls finde ich den halt total
geil weil der direkt auf dieser höhe ist
also hier auf höhe 75 und man kann sich
dann hier richtig geilen mob eine
richtig geile mordfall in bonn werde
einfach auf einer hohen höhe ist so also
dass ein mops ponor dann haben wir hier
eine extreme hält bio ich weiß nicht
genau ob man das
und ich weiß auch nicht ob das gesetz
häufig oder eher seltener auftritt er
hat es jedenfalls noch mal betont in
seiner nachricht an mich dass er bei
diesen koordinaten eine extreme hills
bei ihm ist das sind alles ränder viel
also nicht dass ihr denkt dass da so
elendig große löcher drin sind es
einfach mal eine fackel hinsetzen ist
das weg hier auch aber extrem so also
dann sollte das schon klar gehen also
hier seien extreme hält bei ihm da
hinten findet ihr noch eine schlucht
fordern möchte ich jetzt aber nicht
näher darauf eingehen welche dazu wieder
viel fliegen muss hier allgemeinen geht
auch einfluss her und so weiter sieht
halt eigentlich ganz schön aus hier
alles und halt extrem hohe berge also
extreme hält extreme berge solltet ihr
eigentlich übersetzen können hier sind
auch schafe und so weiter eine kleine
fliegende insel schön
na ja und das letzte was ich euch zeigen
möchte ist
naja jetzt nichts was womit ihr
unbedingt was anfangen könnt aber es
liegt aus einer bestimmten perspektive
aus wie ein meteor einschlag und zwar
von hier sieht so aus als wäre das ein
meteor okay da ist jetzt wieder so ein
händler fehler moment muss ich eben
ausleuchten
dann seht ihr das was ich meine so gut
wenn ihr von hier darauf gibt sieht das
so aus als ob irgend so ein meteor von
dar eingeflogen werden dann daran die
höhle rein weil ich meine guckt euch die
höhle an das sieht echt heftig hammer
epischem things aus also extrem krass
auf jeden fall also noch mal kurz der
sie zusammengefasst ist bond direkt bei
einem dschungel tempel wohl palais
rätsel lösen könnt und wo er direkt ein
diamant ab geht ein stück weiter habt
ihr hier sofort ein hotspot adaptieren
extreme hitze und da ist ein meteor
eingeschlagen und wüstenblume hier im
dschungel billionen normal dass bio
extreme hills und so weiter auf jeden
fall muss ich sagen richtig richtig
geiles sie danke an dich für pinguin lux
schreibt mir weiteres lied in die
kommentare bewertet das video bitte wie
immer wenn es euch gefallen hat mit
einem daumen hoch und wenn ihr es nicht
so gut verhandelt mit einem daumen
runter und dann würde ich mich wieder
über vieles in den kommentaren freund
bis zum nächsten mal läutet